tarot's Tao is one of the world's best
mathematicians he has won maths top
prize the fields medal and many would
consider him a genius his talents were
recognized early and he was a child Math
Prodigy he was dabbling in university
courses when he was nine and by 16 he
had graduated from Flinders University
in Adelaide by 21 he had his PhD from
Princeton when Terence was seven he was
taking some math and physics classes at
his local high school and it was around
this time that he was visited at home by
Ken Clements a researcher of
mathematically gifted children this
report is clements's thoughts and
findings on Tau including the results of
a math test given to him so let's take a
look at it it was the day before
terence's eighth birthday the 16th of
July 1983 exactly 38 years ago and it
says here that Terence was given an
operations test knowing that he might
find the first few questions too easy
Clement says you shouldn't laugh at the
questions because they get it harder
towards the end of the test and Terence
has an interesting reply he says the
questions won't know if I laugh at them
because they haven't got ears he went on
to score a 60 out of 60 on this test on
average a year 12 student taking the
same test would be expected to get a
score of only 53 out of 60. and here's
one of those example questions question
58 asked
P divided by Q divided by R is equal to
Delta divided by Q divided by R then
find Delta and here is seven-year-old
terence's answer he writes it out as a
fraction and then just does a bit of
algebra to rearrange for Delta getting
it to be p over r squared although it
was clear to Clements that this test was
too easy for Terence and they'd need to
move on to some more difficult things
this next set of questions were
presented to him and they had to be
worked out mentally they include things
like what angle does an hour hand
describe in 20 minutes
Terence got all eight of these questions
correct as well in a total time of nine
minutes
Clements noticed that while Terence had
been solving the questions he often
Justified an algebraic step by writing
the appropriate algebraic law for
example the associated law next to it
and so that prompted this following very
interesting conversation Clements asks
what is the associate of law for
addition of real numbers tyrants answers
that it doesn't matter where you put the
brackets he also gives a correct
definition of the commutative laws and
he also gives a correct definition of a
group something that most math students
don't encounter until University however
it seems that the first thing to stump
him was being asked what is a field
Terence replies I don't know given that
I barely have a grasp on what a field is
now I think it's forgivable for a
seven-year-old Terence not to know that
either he does however know about the
distributive law and gives the example
multiplication over addition Clements
asks if addition over multiplication is
an exam sample but Terence replies only
for Boolean algebras Clements was quite
impressed by all of this not only did he
have an astounding grasp of algebraic
definitions for someone who was still
seven years old but I was amazed at how
he used sophisticated mathematical
language freely I was beginning to form
the impression that Terence preferred to
use analytic non-visual methods in
preference to making extensive use of
visual imagery here's one of terence's
actual written solutions to a question
that says the length of each side of a
square is increased by three meters the
area of the new square is 39 meters
squared more than that of the original
Square how long are the sides of the new
Square Terence correctly finds that the
length of the new square is 8 meters the
next set of questions given to Terence
include suppose you decide to write down
all the numbers from 1 to 99
999 how many times would you have to
write the number one this one Terence
actually gave an incorrect solution to
although still an answer that shows
plenty of critical thought about the
question apparently the correct solution
here is fifty thousand he struggled a
little bit with a few more of these
questions and Clement says that at this
stage Terence was showing slight signs
of fatigue although his interest was
still high so he asked him just two more
relatively simple questions first he
asked him to sketch the graph of y
equals x squared plus X which he did
immediately I asked him to find the
coordinates of the turning point and he
wrote them down this response took 20
seconds I then asked him to sketch Y is
equal to X cubed minus two x squared
plus X and in about one minute he
produced this it is interesting to note
that Terence hadn't begun to study any
calculus at school but when Clements had
arrived at the tower household and was
speaking with terence's parents Billy
and Grace he had spotted Terence sitting
in the far corner of the room reading a
book with the title calculus terence's
dad was a doctor and terence's Mum was a
graduate of physics and maths who had
worked as a high school teacher she said
that Terence liked to read mathematics
by himself and often spent three or four
hours after school reading mathematics
textbooks Terence also had an interest
in computer programming and had taught
himself basic Language by reading a book
and at the end of this first visit
Clements was shown one of terence's
programs it was called Fibonacci and
actually contains plenty of humor
apparently Terence wrote many of his
programs when he was just six years old
so let's take a look at Fibonacci it
doesn't just calculate the sequence it
starts with Here Comes Mr Fibonacci can
you guess which year was Mr Fibonacci
born
write down a number please then if the
user inputs the correct answer they can
start however if their guess is too far
off they'll be told no he is already in
heaven try again or they might be told
sorry he wasn't born yet try again then
if they were close it would print the
difference between the guests and the
actual answer meaning that even to start
this program the user is Guided by a bit
of mathematics after printing some of
the sequence it ends with Mr Fibonacci
is leaving now and here goes his car
this line is perhaps the only reminder
of just how young the author of this
program is
five weeks later Clements came back for
a second visit and he asked Terence if
something was a field here was terence's
answer clearly demonstrating that since
the last visit he now knew exactly what
a field was this kind of answer is
something that a university student
would be proud of and it shows just how
fast Terence was able to learn Concepts
they encountered another thing though
that he didn't know yet he was asked for
the anti-derivative of 1 over X and
responded that he had not got up to that
yet in his reading but on a third visit
not long after the second Terence had
not only mastered the antiderivative of
1 over X but was doing things like this
with partial fractions he was given a
space visualization test which again
made Clements come to the conclusion
that Terence preferred to use non-visual
analytic methods even if they required
more complicated thinking then more
visual methods for example with this
question here Terence said that he
checked each shape by the reflection law
which was that each point had an image
on the other side of the mediator and he
did not imagine each shape being folded
along the dotted line
included in the report was terence's
school timetable the subjects marked
with the asterisks took place at the
primary school whilst all the others
took place at the high school his
teachers said that whilst seven-year-old
Terence did have the academic ability of
a 16 year old his maturity was still
that of a seven-year-old and terence's
parents had to balance giving him a
childhood that challenged him
intellectually but also allowed him to
fit in socially and emotionally the
report makes it clear that rather than
being pushed along one rigid track of
mathematical education Terence was
allowed to pursue the topics that
interested and challenged him the most
he loved mathematics and the efforts of
those around him were to ensure that he
did not become bored or frustrated with
non-challenging work let's finish with a
look at a program that now
eight-year-old Terence Tao had submitted
for publication to a student mathematics
Journal called Trigon it is all about
perfect numbers and is labeled here as
terence's first published paper a
perfect number is one such that all its
factors including one but excluding
itself add up to itself for example six
is a perfect number because 6 has
factors one two three and six and one
plus two plus three is equal to six
Euclid proved that a number of this form
is a perfect number if 2 to the P minus
1 is a prime number so Terence says that
he has used this fact to write a program
in basic to find perfect numbers which
starts with a program for checking if 2
to the P minus 1 is prime then he
computes perfect numbers up to 10 to the
13. yet again another example of just
how outstanding he is it's been humbling
for me to read through these notes I
hope that it doesn't seem discouraging
to any aspiring mathematicians out there
as I'm sure Terence Tao would even agree
that many of the Great mathematicians
followed a more conventional path
through education thanks for watching I
hope you've enjoyed this video and
thanks as always to my patreon
supporters for making these videos
possible a special shout out to today's
patreon cat of the day Leon